Oh
at some point in our lives most of us
have probably wished we could live
forever being immortal sounds pretty
good at first essentially not aging
after a certain point being unable to
die of natural causes not a bad life but
what if everyone became immortal
overnight what if the entire worlds
population stopped dying at the current
rate approximately 150 to thousand
people die every day around the world
that's about two per second so assuming
our immortality event happens instantly
that would mean two unlucky souls would
miss it by as little as a fraction of a
second if we assume everyone stopped
dying at the time of making this video
the world population would quickly start
climbing from about seven point six
billion at the current rate about three
hundred sixty thousand people are born
each day and the current death rate
slows apparent population growth by
about 42% when this immortality event
occurred we'd begin to see dramatic
changes to our society
contrary to what you'd probably expect
overpopulation wouldn't be the first
problem we'd have to deal with if people
stopped dying the population would start
to increase more quickly but it wouldn't
become a crisis for at least a few years
one of the first negative impacts of
this change would likely be the ironic
death of the funeral industry if no one
dies of natural causes there's no one to
bury no funerals to arrange no caskets
to sell funeral homes would have to rely
on victims of violent crime car
accidents and other unnatural causes of
death to make a living
meanwhile in hospitals people sick with
formerly terminal illnesses would exist
in a permanent state of pain unable to
die and their families would be stuck
with their continued medical bills these
hospitals would begin to become
overcrowded as new patients are admitted
for various unnatural injuries and
conditions when the world begins to feel
the strain of overpopulation especially
after children are born grow up and
start having children of their own we'd
begin to see crises in several areas
first natural resources would be
depleted at an alarming rate fossil
fuels already running out today
would be used up much more quickly
forcing the world to adopt new sources
of energy to keep society running
available land supply would dwindle with
new housing springing up in any vacant
lot to accommodate the rapidly growing
population even if we could keep up with
the demand for housing young people
entering the job market would be met
with little to no opportunity for
employment all the jobs already
snatched up by those who came before
them as the unemployed begin to pile up
homelessness would become a real problem
made worse by the spike in housing
prices when space inevitably runs out
natural food would come at a premium as
land used for livestock or crops would
dwindle and suffer under the strain of
so many new mouths to feed the food
industry would have to turn to heavily
processed and cheaply manufactured food
potentially causing even more widespread
nutritional problems than we have today
with so many people out of work homeless
and hungry and with no room to spread
out
civil unrest would start building we'd
begin to see riots in the streets of
major cities anywhere there's a
concentrated population of the
unemployed on a larger scale nations
without room for their citizens may feel
the obligation to challenge their
neighbors for their territory or
resources sparking large Wars
governments would probably secretly see
these Wars as serving multiple purposes
to expand their territory and living
space but also to help thin the
population then there are more extreme
possibilities with all other options
exhausted perhaps we'd see a real-life
implementation of death sports like
those in The Hunger Games or ancient
Rome may be forced euthanasia would
become the norm for the unfit both young
and old in order to allow the healthiest
members of society to survive or more
realistically we might see stringent
restrictions on the number of children
allowed per family perhaps based on
social status occupation or income but
if we could get the population growth
under control the human race might not
be as doomed as we think we'd certainly
have to live more frugal lives and
likely have much less space to spread
out but with the right regulations in
place it could be sustainable at least
for the near future in the wake of our
new immortality we might see new
technologies developed to accommodate
the larger and longer lived population
homes designed to allow humans to live
in areas once considered undesirable
allowing the more adventurous people to
have a bit more space at the expense of
safety or convenience technological
progress would likely increase as the
demand for new innovations to help ease
the population strain would grow and
longer lives would allow scientists and
innovators more time to perform studies
and develop new ideas provided the world
didn't collapse beforehand on a personal
level we might become more creative and
artistic our longer lives allowing us to
pursue new hobbies and skills over
decades instead of limiting ourselves to
a few we'd have the chance to live
smaller mini lives living in one place
for 50 years then moving and pursuing a
new career somewhere else if the world
could sustain such a drastic change it
would be interesting to see what an
immortal society would look like of
course it's very unlikely that it would
as the strain from so many new mouths to
feed and people to house would simply be
too much
luckily immortality probably isn't
something will ever have to accommodate
and certainly not overnight what do you
think what would an immortal society
look like and what changes would you
expect to see in the world let us know
your thoughts in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video make sure to
subscribe to keep up to date with the
latest content you can watch my previous
video by clicking here or if you're
really bored you can binge watch all my
content by clicking here thanks for
watching and I'll see you next week
[Music]